conundrum though like in the for the
book right oh yeah I've got an audio
recording actually in South Bank
pose and the road works and how do I do
audio recording so three days in a room
for the audio book how the [__] am I
gonna do the voices of people in the
book because I can't be like oh could
you stand this is so good to meet you
I can't like [__] try and do like
impressions are you kidding me I think
your audience will [__] love that I
could see some issues arising but
there's only one voice actor here and
he's called seed of it what Would You Do
Well I voiced the Nigerian archers
myself uh has that said the test of time
no but you'd remove it so uh I would I
what you I'll just do your like a a
different voice but not racist
it's pretty easy you don't have to go oh
you know like you don't have to do that
[__] like what the [__] you just like
you just change up your voice it's tough
though is it how would I be like I mean
you've done it you've done it you've
done Impressions
it's the grammatical structure just
isn't there so it's easy to be like oh
yeah just do your yeah but you you
normally do oh Chris but I feel like I
feel like yeah yeah yeah yeah you just
just do it in your own voice just being
like and then natsuki said always
[__] place
a little bit Yeah you gotta you gotta
let the readers know that the voice has
changed scary oh no it's fine yeah it's
fine I can't do an American accent I do
an Australian accent well I'm you can
try it means you can't say the word
Umami without doing an American mommy
flavor yeah
it's pretty good for some reason
whatever the word Umami comes into
Chris's diet uh like vocabulary yeah
Umami flavors
why is that I don't [__] know it's
because I saw it on NHK World once right
where they like only hire American
presenters and that's all they say
Umami flavor went to the restaurant we
had Umami flavors all over my face
that's NHK well see Pete Macy I'm here
too you're gonna do all of that this
entire book in three days three days
two thousand how many words is this uh
eighty thousand eighty thousand words in
three days how many pages
300. yeah yeah it's very durable
well you have better reading skills than
me if that's just throw up was it
chapter five
so like for me when I was doing audio
books I didn't [__] know what the
book was about and they'd be like and
the elves took their shorts and
conquered me and I was like what the
[__] is this [__] that I'm reading like
I don't know what I was reading and uh
you know because when you do audiobooks
as well obviously you can't read the
book and then do it you read the book
while I'm doing it yeah yeah so that was
the hard part I did do a test read
through the other day and I was laughing
at my own jokes
that's a good thing that means
Chris laugh at your own jokes yeah I
don't know if that's pretty lame that's
good or maybe not in the recording just
give me like chapter five Mr dick like
how the [__] am I gonna do that
I just want the audio recording yeah I
saw the audio recording of that that's
my new text tone chapter seven the
sausages
already I'm definitely
you didn't think about doing it in Japan
yesterday
[Laughter]
oh man over here I was on YouTube
flicking through like you do which you
should never do
the home page
it's a dribble of wine for you thanks
yeah I saw a video that triggered me go
on it wasn't even seed over here
it was white girl speaks Japanese to
Japanese people Japanese people [__]
themselves oh yeah yeah or is this a
video I want to know do you ever watch
like I'm gonna guess you don't watch
Tick Tock at all and you don't seem like
a Tick-Tock guy I despise Tick Tock but
you the day that Chris comes after me
and says did you see thing on tick tock
you I I you might be aware of like
YouTube shorts right
what's your opinion of like the new wave
like YouTube shorts which is like here's
some weird things in Japan number one
top five things that you didn't know
existed in Japan every time I see it I'm
just like I want to buy an island I just
live there and [__] turn off the
internet
like when YouTube shots are kicking off
I was speaking to YouTube and they're
like we think it would be really great
Chris if you could do some YouTube
shorts I was like how about [__] off and
uh not you know I know YouTube shorts
for some people and I get it yeah yeah
but I hate them it's not my demographic
I did one on a broader Japan once for
people like the [__] is this because my
demographics like a 32 year old white
man in Swindon and like and maybe more
that's it that's the entirely guy the
entire population it could be the David
Adler of Japan why demographics older
people I say older people like people
who are 25 to 35 yeah who are less Keen
to watch shorts yeah I don't watch
shorts I hate them and it is literally
just did you know there's a ferry in
Japan that you can ride and it goes
across the sea and I found if any
machine you get pikari sweat and you
[__] yourself and it's like oh
my [__] time I spend my videos and
shorts like just crap videos where's
annoyance come with the shorts is it
because they're you feel like they're
lower quality or is it because you think
they cover stuff in a superficial way
okay nice superficial I don't know just
Japan feels like more more like a
playground for [__] content yeah like
content creators coming over in Spades
now just it's everywhere you know I I
don't want to be like the gatekeeper of
Japan yeah
you do that's literally the last 10
years I've spent here yeah every far
like a lot far as I speak to if you want
to make a YouTube Sean Japan you have to
go through me it's literally like top
trumps when you sometimes meet a foreign
been in Japan yeah well I've been here
yeah seven years since I've been in nine
an immortal dude yeah that does happen I
hate those and I don't want to be like
that right but there are you know people
coming over here
I haven't met anyone yet more years so
it feels good I don't know
um and I think this you will actually
get a kick out of this one uh [__] this
had me cringing in a sense that I oh my
god I've never had such I don't mind
shorts for comedy necessarily yeah I
need a quick joke funny yeah but just
boiling down something into seconds it
robs it of any emotional
promoting a product Like A Book Like A
Book Like A Book Like A book
I bought a book in Japan I made a book
in Japan it's just like yourself you're
so good your [__]
don't you know there's a book about
Japan that's so good you'll come
yeah
YouTube sure just just be like here's
one weird thing that happened to uh in
Japan or like and you just tell the
story it's a short story and if you want
to buy you can find out more in my book
yeah if you find out more stories I
wrote a book all of my life in Japan
there you go perfect perfect you can
make it in 60 seconds and I never
thought I'd see the day gone was trying
to sell me on YouTube shorts
what is this I can't I can't my trip to
Japan is over already
I said I can't believe my trip to Japan
is over already
be fair it is pretty rude to put in
earbuds while someone's trying to talk
to you
well was your trip as adventurous as
mine was there were some new specialty
vending machines I didn't see on my last
trip and it
when you live here you don't look
Japanese and yeah I would know I've seen
several anime that take place in Japan
itself so what the [__] is this so well
I bet my knowledge of Japan is better
than yours
hey no backing out of this one you
challenged my knowledge to the greatest
country on Earth so there's no backing
out of this one
I'll start with the first question okay
question one what is the age of consent
in Japan oh my God no that's actually
not correct because if it was I'd be in
jail right now what is this is this real
like that's a parody it's a parody
Japan I suppose too much it does happen
quite a lot yeah yeah I've unfortunately
met a few people who are like that yeah
well I think I think some people will
comment as well they're like you guys
just don't [__] hate Japan why are
you there and it's like no no no you
know some people get questions yeah
comments like that on the show oh well
it's always that if you critical of
Japan anyway you always get destroyed by
someone yeah I mean if you've been here
long enough I think you'll just have
come complaints well I'm working on a
video now to promote the book a little
bit because 10 years in Japan the good
the bad the ugly and I'm at that scary
bit where I'm like scripting the ugly
bit and it's like oh I'm gonna talk
about that like you know there's some
things you just don't talk about the
issue
it's like the ugly you know so I've got
to tread carefully yeah careful how I do
that Orchestra Japan's problems are
pretty pretty real problems there are
lots of problems you know I still think
the net on the net yeah very positive
that's always quite a preface with like
you know yeah it's because you know
sometimes I what I what I do dislike is
that sometimes I'll be like a tick tock
show like these are the top five vetting
machine in Japan the top the first reply
be like why is rape so underreported in
Japan again it's like whoa
these energies aren't matching like it's
like someone who's trying to like on it
on it like enjoy Japan and then someone
who's like absolutely trying to be like
it's a terrible country the sexual crime
is higher than the US and it's like okay
well I feel it's so weird as well
because Japan is one of the few
countries where that phenomena happens
where it's like if someone who's a
foreigner is like hey guys by the way
I'm moving to Japan tomorrow yeah and
then there's always that one person
that's like you know that like the
sexual crime rate in Japan is like
really [__] and it's like okay
thanks I guess I mean it is but like you
know you don't but any other country you
don't get that that's what I find
interesting about YouTube shorts and
Tick Tock comments in general yes
because like because Shores and tick
tocks are just reaching an audience that
are like are so vastly bigger than you
get on like a stream or like Long
YouTube videos you just see what kind of
comments you'd get if your content would
be recommended to people just like
outside of your own interests yeah right
so it's like you get some of the most
[__] unhinged comments you have like
all time oh my God I don't like shorts
and tick tocks they're just kind of
crazy sometimes now to see someone who
just gets like an order from McDonald's
and they like 10 million views because
they're just talking about like shacky
tricky it's like it's just chicken
Shake
short views are worthless yeah both
literally and financially like I was
speaking to someone they got like 10
million views it's like yeah a dollar
it's like wow I mean it sucks because I
I've been very resistant to them for a
long time but I've recently started kind
of trying to do them more because
just the people I just spoke to are like
yeah it's kind of you've got to do it
you've got to do it and also YouTube is
only going to keep incentivizing it more
and more right now it's not maybe not
the best but it's uh slowly and slowly
they're putting more eggs in that basket
at least they're paying you on like Tick
Tock you know so that's already in the
right way yeah yeah let's at least one
good thing yeah yeah my short channel
gets more views than all my other
channels combined I know obviously the
views is very different usually yeah I
know all right you know which service
but I know a big uh YouTuber in Japan uh
who has millions of views on shorts and
millions of subscribers as a result by
his main views don't go above like 20 to
50 000 yeah what is the point of that
that's the problem I would much rather
have an audience that's there for the
long form content well a lot more
thoughts generally gone into it yeah
focusing on your topic but you can feel
emotion and try and get something like
Best of Both Worlds you can do both you
can do both and maybe I should explore
it yeah but I'd rather chop my fingers
off
I hate that pressure of having to do
shorts I've had so many people YouTube
and organizations
you need to do shorts it's like no I
don't yeah I just shut the YouTube
channel down and go and [__] read a
book for 10 years honestly my book
that's I'll say all right I hate viewing
YouTube through the prism of business
I've always all I give a [__] about is
trying to make a good video [__]
throw my energy into that video Yeah and
release into the wild yeah
you've got to do YouTube shorts man
you've got to do this you've got to do
that and it's like no I just want to
make a video in it yeah like yeah I hate
that pressure yeah that's ever present I
guess the problem is you just don't know
where the platforms are going a lot of
the times it's very hard to be like oh a
lot of eggs are being put in this basket
more than I had originally anticipated
now I'm [__] because I didn't adapt